and listen you know i'm still
you know constantly you know i
want to say disbelief at this particular
point in time man but it's just a
surreal moment
guys nobody really knows
you know how excited i am you know just
to be a part of this this organization
in in many ways that one
uh just following up such a a a powerful
dynasty with with that is enriched and
so much prestige lineage of success
that you know for me a lot of people
would
would hide from the notion to do certain
things but for me man i think this
opportunity is is something that
i wake up pinching myself each and every
day and it's so surreal
you know
you know coming down one patriot place
each and every day and you know seeing
the whole ambiance it's not only that
but seeing such
so much support around the city of
boston and foxborough and
you know it's just it's just such a
great a great environment you know for
not only myself but you know players
included
and uh
you know i
it's crazy i just found myself putting
on you know shirts that's like oh my god
i don't know when that moment is going
to be but i'm just going to keep doing
what i'm supposed to do while i'm a
member of the patriots so that you know
soon that it it will click that that
this is the norm
cam newton from last week talking about
his experiences so far as new england
patriot chris and and
you know one of the talking points last
week came from kyle love former patriot
former panther
the notion that
cam newton was coddled in carolina he's
not going to be coddled in new england
because bill belichick didn't cuddle tom
brady he doesn't sound like a guy who's
been chewed out in the film room yet and
i don't know that that's ever going to
happen because you've got to keep cam
newton in a positive state of mind
you've got to keep him with that energy
with that fire with that passion the
challenge becomes what happens when you
get to it and it may not happen it may
not happen all year when you get to a
spot where it's not going their way and
we've seen him before we've seen the
demeanor we've seen the disappointment
we've seen him just want to pack it in
and go home that day
when when is that moment going to arrive
when he's going to want to pinch himself
for a very different reason well they're
going to break them in they they will
that i can i can promise you and you
know he'll realize pretty quickly within
being there that you know it's about
today it's about the next thing you know
don't worry about all the external
motivation factors all those things new
england's always going to stay on that
belichick mcdaniels that coaching staff
and it's all going to be about the next
challenge and the next obstacle so he's
going to realize like right away that
sulking or being disappointed about a
throw or decision he made in practice
he's gonna see that like this group
doesn't care in new england they're not
they're not like on the field gonna be
like ah cam what are you doing one of
the things that'll always jump out to me
about new england was during practice it
was practice time when we get in the
meeting room we'll coach you and tell
you what you did wrong but on the field
we want you to play and go and not like
be looking over the sidelines like you
know wait let me get my instructions for
mommy and daddy over here bill is not
into that so he's gonna learn from that
and then i would think what also breaks
him in a little mike is just of course
he's getting a feel for i'm sure how
things are communicated during meetings
and he's starting to realize whoa
even when you do good here they're still
pretty stern about talking to you and
what you did and coaching you up so man
i better brace myself for when i do
something bad that it's not going to be
like oh cam don't worry you know we'll
get him next time i think he's got to
probably have a good sense of what that
is right now and of course of course
with his motivation and the way he was
screwed over this offseason hopefully
he'll be ready to accept all those
challenges
nothing against ron rivera yeah he
walked into that job with cam newton as
the number one overall pick in the draft
the heisman trophy winner
and and he was a lot younger in 2011
than he is now we all were but uh i i
think it was it's a different mindset
it's a different approach than when you
are bill belichick when you have the six
rings that you've won as a head coach
plus two others as a defensive
coordinator when you have a guy who was
basically left for dead by the nfl and
nobody wanted him
you you you have a lot more freedom to
give him the kind of coaching that maybe
he would have benefited from in carolina
but the circumstances didn't allow it
and speaking of circumstances the
circumstances caused him to be available
in delayed june caused him to be
overlooked he was asked last week if
he's extra motivated based upon the way
things ended in carolina here's what he
had to say
look i wake up man
you know i'm saying i don't i don't need
no the fact that i'm not able to see my
kids on a regular basis that's what
makes me mad so
you know at the end of the day you know
for me i'm not going to dwell on the
past
you know i i think i'm a person that's a
self-motivator
and you know even though
the past is a pass i'm not going to keep
looking back and
you know for me just turn the page and
move forward you know i wish those guys
nothing but the best and you know i hope
that the feeling is mutual and uh moving
on
that's a mature and a proper response
from cam newton and i think at his core
he gets it he understands what the
panthers were trying to do they were
trying to get trade value for the final
year of a contract that paid only 19
million dollars and of course he would
have gotten a new contract as part of
that but the problem is he wasn't
healthy you throw in the pandemic you
throw in the desire to try to get value
for the guy who was the first overall
pick in the draft you throw in the
lingering health questions it becomes
impossible to work it out yeah we wish
that they would have just cut him when
they cut greg olsen right after the
super bowl absolutely but you know as
much as we can fault the panthers for
how they handled it and i don't think
they handled it perfectly by any means
the circumstances he had a lot more to
do with what happened yeah no i i think
that's fair you're right i mean hey i
would have liked to have seen it a
little bit a little smoother for cam
newton as far as you know his release
and and all of that but you're right
they were in a tough position they were
certainly trying to protect their own
interests to to help their own football
team um but but you know one thing i
think you know worth hitting on too you
talk about that environment with cam
newton and when you're the number one
pick in carolina panthers it's very
common in football it really is and i'm
sorry to say it or if that's
disappointing to people but yeah you
know in certain organizations
yes the star players you come in and you
perform in a star level right away
you know i for lack of a better phrase i
think i've said this before it's just
you know they roll out the red carpet
you become almost king of the
organization you know a lot like a brett
favre with the green bay packers and
then aaron rodgers taking over they
become almost bigger than the team
because they're so damn good and they do
so many things where they go well
our team wouldn't have won this game
today that that guy won the game for us
today he helped the team out like
immensely and that's where cam newton
was so yes because of that that like
rolls downhill into bad habits you know
between him and the way he's coached and
he's allowed you know a little
flexibility with how he acts none of
that goes on in new england none of it
and that's that's that's gonna be the
refreshing thing for cam newton i think
he's gonna like it in a lot of ways and
uh i think we've seen a lot of players
be able to adapt to that and i think the
more time that goes on the more i feel
like he is going to adapt and this is
going to be a good thing and this won't
be the ocho cinco albert hainsworth
failed you know chemistry uh experiment
or the reggie wayne see you later that
one should be camp this isn't fun
anymore i don't think that's going to be
happening with cam newton at some point
it comes down to x's and o's however and
he's got to learn that offense the
offense has to adapt to him we've had
that conversation in a lot of different
ways as it relates to tom brady we
haven't talked about it much as it
relates to cam newton he was asked last
week about josh mcdaniels comparing the
patriots offense to calculus here's some
of what cam newton had to say first time
i called him you know we were both
excited just to be on the phone with
each other then all of a sudden he just
said hey bro this
this explicit is calculus
and uh
and he said it and it was just you know
funny it was just from that whole
15-minute conversation that's the only
thing that i just remember calculus he's
a smart football player you know he uh
he's played a lot of football he's seen
a lot of stuff so
um
you know guys guys uh in our league i
think rarely have the type of success
that a player like he has had in his
past without you know understanding the
games
they need to work on the lighting and
the spacing for some of those josh
mcdaniel it's like bam
right there it's like we walked up to
his car with a flashlight and a a video
camera but that's new england they don't
even give a damn they don't care he's
literally like can i get the hell out of
here and go coach the team i mean that's
why they're awesome that's why i always
respect them you know it's just a
different way of life i mean literally i
can picture josh he probably walked in
there they were like hey can we fix the
light he's like nah the hell with it
let's go and they just go but yeah i
mean
uh i mean what's your thoughts on
hearing cam and what he said in josh and
what he said there mike
i i think the bottom line is this
they're not going to give him anything
more than they think he can handle yeah
and that's part of the test right they
know that they have a guy who hasn't
been in that system they also have a guy
who brings to the table a skill set that
his predecessor didn't have
and you have to factor that into which
plays you're going to show i mean good
coaching is taking the guys you have
and enhancing the things they do well
and covering up the things they don't do
well
and that's what they're in the process
of figuring out with cam newton and my
guess is josh mcdaniel started that
process before they even signed it uh
hunter when they decide to do it uh bill
says josh
what would we do give me an idea we want
to sit down and work this out what plays
would we run with cam newton i want to
see film i want to see what he's done
what we've done and how you're going to
make it fit before we do this yeah
exactly right and they're you know
they're they're too well thought out
there in new england you know even added
to that
i don't think they would even sign cam
newton unless they got the answers they
wanted in their investigation process of
cam newton and whether they thought he
could fit their football team unless
they got answers that they wanted you
know in that process i think if they got
answers like oh i'm not sure he'll be
able to learn you know that calculus
playbook and all the rules you're all
you know if they got those type of
answers they might have not done it but
i i think they were led to believe that
yes like josh just said you know cam's a
smart football player he's played a lot
of football yeah is he going to be tom
brady mad scientist you know reading
defenses all that no maybe not but
you're right they're going to be able to
formulate an offense around him that
they've never had in new england
i had a flashback there to when ron
rivera was coaching the panthers in the
light bulb finally was coming on for cam
newton and it was starting to really
work for him he explained to me at the
time mike schuler then the offensive
coordinator went back to auburn and
found the stuff that cam newton liked to
do
they've already done that new england
they've already found the stuff cam
newton likes and he's in the process of
learning at new england
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports